ich sitze nicht hier um anzuklagen
sondern um zu fragen und um eventuelle
antworten aus dieser runde auch zu
bekommen also heute früh habe ich drei
minuten im frühstücksfernsehen zur
kenntnis nehmen müssen dass die junge
von linde ochsenknecht geschwängerte
junge frau demnächst mutter wird sie
weiß aber nicht ob sie den vater des
kindes in den kreißsaal mitnehmen soll
und hat deswegen eine ins zeitraum
umfrage gemacht da haben 200.000
menschen reagiert 80.000 haben gesagt
nehmen mit 120000 nicht das waren
200.000 jungen menschen die zu hause
kinder brüder schwestern mütter omas
onkels haben die im altenheim sitzen und
die sie nicht besuchen das geht sie in
gottes namen nichts an und 80 prozent
dessen was uns heute bewegen soll geht
uns eigentlich nichts an es ist völlig
unerheblich ob jetzt eine influenza in
diese oder jene meinung hat aber es gibt
hunderttausende junger menschen die
folgen die die die diese follower
mentalität dass man das leben eines
anderen mit lebt die was am gekenterten
250 millionen das sind zu einem großen
prozentsatz junger menschen die die
wahrscheinlich nicht wissen was aus
ihnen wird die alle davon träumen auch
influenza oder frau kardashian zu werden
was sie nie erreichen werden aber
nichtsdestotrotz sie sind blockiert sie
leben fremde leben mit das begreife ich
nicht das muss man mir erklären und es
werden immer neue stars in dieser arena
nach gefühlt ich habe gestern habe ich
in einem restaurant in münchen da kam
eine junge frau rein und ich kannte sie
natürlich nicht haben sie aber heute
früh als influenza rinn und spielerfrau
in irgendeinem morgenmagazin das foto
von ihr gesehen influenza rinn und
spielerfrau das ist heute ein ein
prädikat mit dem man schon
ganz gut dabei sein kann ja ich verstehe
es nicht ich verstehe es nicht aber es
ist eben auch so dass natürlich früher
irgendwelche medien sich aus diesen
sachen raus gehalten haben ich habe
heute im spiegel online spiegel hat mit
von mir zum beispiel zurecht bis zum
fünfzigsten lebensjahr keine notiz
genommen obwohl ich relativ viel im
fernsehen unterwegs war aber heute wurde
ernst ist berichtet bei spiegel online
dass frau thomalla von ihrem handballer
verlassen wurde was mich schwer
getroffen hat aber da hat simone
thomalla simone thomalla ja also das
heißt es gibt zwei genau die andere die
ist ja schon verlassen aber
nichtsdestotrotz ist es einfach für mich
nicht nachvollziehbar dass diese
nachrichten fülle aus diesem in
anführungszeichen promi influenza und
sonstigen bereich so etwas stark über
uns her eine welle kommt er über uns ich
verstehe es mich wenn ich da einsteigen
darf ich verstehe jetzt ehrlich gesagt
auch nicht und ich mache das auch sehr
sehr traurig weil natürlich auch gerade
jüngere menschen mit dem glauben
aufwachsen dass das die realität dass
das die normalität ist es gibt studien
darüber dass sich mädchen zum 18
geburtstag lieber die teilfinanzierung
von einem von der brust op anstatt die
von einem studium wünschen so weit ist
es schon dass es mehr darum optik geht
anstatt dank ins inhalte ja also ich bin
nicht traurig darüber ich bin extrem
glücklich darüber weil ich finde dass
vieles von dem natürlich kann man immer
beispiele wählen die dann das gegenteil
belegen aber vieles von dem gibt
menschen die sich dann in diese
situation versetzen wenn ich ein
beispiel so doch das gefühl dass andere
auch ähnliche probleme haben ich finde
zum beispiel das stück fernsehen der
stufe 1 kritisiert hast dass
irgendjemand eine umfrage gemacht ob man
bei der geburt des kindes der mann dabei
sein soll finde ich das finde ich
nachgerade genial dienste weiter dazu
sagen weil sich diese frage glaube ich
in ganz vielen partnerschaften stellt
und ich glaube übrigens wenn ich das
auch noch sagen darf dass die antwort
meistens verlogen ist ich glaube viele
männer sagen da muss ich jetzt mit aber
das mit ihm weiter und so weiter und
genau diese frage also wollen eigentlich
gar nicht aber denken ist sozial
erwartet und genau da rein und genau
nennen nicht nur instagram aber
instagram ist auch ein neues
massenmedium und es waren immer die
themen in massenmedien zu versuchen an
konkreten beispielen idealerweise von
menschen die man kennt jedermann und
jederfrau ist probleme zu zeigen und das
ist jetzt einfach nur vervielfältigt
also ich bin begierig folge zum beispiel
frau kardashian auf instagram und dann
habe das erhöhte sich weiter die hat
heute alle seine fotos gelöscht bist du
ersetzt
also da gerne einmal kardashian jetzt
setzt das institut das finde ich kann
man schon sagen thomas zurzeit von dir
saßen den großen stars auf seiner couch
bei wetten das instrument die prominenz
zerstört ich meine winde ist wen würdest
du jetzt einlagen wenn heute show machen
würdest wenn müsste schon dann ein laden
dann müsstest du doch auch die großen
influenza einladen oder wahrscheinlich
wenn man mir sie nennen würde also ich
würde heute nicht wir wissen wenig
einladen wenn ich sophia loren einlade
die oft da war da sagen die jungen leute
was ist dafür eine braungebrannte ist
die erste von der sonnenbank geflüchtet
oder was man kennt die auch wisse nicht
mehr wenn du ein laden sein verwenden
dass ich wusste nicht mehr wie ich eine
bank zusammen bekomme wo jeder der
zuschauer jeden kennt also in florida
frau wäre ein platz der oft besetzt
werden wenn wir auf diese ist ja glaube
ich also ich finde auch also ich find
auch diese dienste influenza und
spielerfrau und dann mit seinem also von
euch allen eigentlich mit seinem
leichten
schädlich für junge mädchen ich werde
ich habe sehr viel temperaturen aber
jetzt die moralpolizei gegenüber
abgelehnt wir sind keine moral wir
wollen wir auch nur so machen jetzt habe
ich da machen wir einfach so und durch
senden sich wenn man sie auf den anguckt
ist instagram schädlicher als tabak und
zigaretten und wenn man sich andere
studien anguckt sieht man auch wie
schlimm das verhalten auch von jungen
mädchen nicht wenn sie dem immer wieder
jeden tag bei wohn und damit zugeballert
werden ich meine was du gesagt das ist
ja nicht gerade von denen nette floskel
das sind 18 mädchen lieber eine
teilfinanzierung von der bus tp münchen
als das studium eher sind falsche weg
ich bin ausdrücklich nicht eure meinung
aber was ist dann euer vorschlag also
der vorschlag muss genau ich sag mal das
was nachher ja mein thema wird sich sag
mal dass ich sage wir brauchen die
verantwortung zurück und die die die
follower haben haben auch kleinere
vereine verantwortung und wenn die dann
das ausnutzen dann finde ich das
allerhand und das sollte auch öffentlich
mal kritisiert werden dass man nicht aus
solchen dass man so etwas macht dann am
schluss dann mehr probleme hat weil man
sagt aber nutzt die volle
denn sagen wenn ich sage wir haben einen
kunden die bei uns trigema kaufen da
kann ich nicht plötzlich sagen jetzt
verändere ich meine qualität die merkten
dass ja nicht und ich mache zum gleichen
preis die halbe qualität das wäre betrug
an einen kunden suchen und die visuelle
haben auch eine verpflichtung gegenüber
in ihrer zuhörer wenn kati hummels die
inzwischen ex frau von mats hummels
wenn wenn wenn katie holmes die auch
viele follower hatte ich weiß nicht
genau
ja aber wenn die am tag oder kurz nach
der trennung ein sexy foto von ihr
postet und damit sozusagen die leute die
das dann schaue ich mir das erstens an
thomas und zweitens glaube ich dass sie
damit die emotionen vieler verlassener
grad getrennter frau und tritt sozusagen
nehmen kann weil ich noch mal der frauen
da einigt wohltäterin wofür du also
dafür holt people sozusagen punkt ich
sage nur das ist in gewisser weise ein
vorbild ob euch das als gutes vorbild
als schlechtes vorbild oder sonst was
vorkommt ist ist ein vorher und
entscheidend ist doch dass diejenigen
die szenen sollten wir managen lassen wo
ist denn ein foto von sich auf dem sie
strahlt dann schreiben 700 influenza du
bist toll gänsehaut pur du bist aber du
bist so schön du bist hektar also ich
glaube dass das macht das macht mich
nervös
als als als als vater der ich der ich in
dieser form nicht mehr bin weil meine
meine söhne sind inzwischen so alt wie
wie du befriedigt aber alles in allem
ist es etwas was wir sorge macht weil
ich irgendwo ich glaube das weiß was du
machen können ist da gehe ich war zum
beispiel gestern unsere wiebke die hier
saß die leben gewinnt ja ja schon zwei
angesetzt ja eine klare ja frau die sich
für politik auch er einen kamin
interessiert auch auch argumentieren
kann eloquent weint haben wie alle
markierungen 6 aber das neue blatt hatte
auch immer viele hunderttausend und
irgendwie haben die sie seit 53 anwalt
hat und im kurs
nein das ist sozusagen ihr macht ich
finde wir sitzen doch wie laut am markt
für die kisten sitzen hier wenn ich das
richtig sehe wir haben viel geld aus dem
markt gezogen sie machen ist wenn wir
sagt man es auch
laut der markt bekenner sein und jetzt
wird sozusagen auf die kunden geschimpft
die sagen wer sein angebot und das nehme
ich wahr sein auf die anleihen aber klar
ist aber dass es doch wirklich also ich
bin da total bei thomas und ich bin ja
auch nicht mir fehlen die die prominente
fehlen die stars ich meine wir beinen
sitzen zusammen und die erheblichkeit
das lief dann erhält es muss doch jemand
mir geben der näher bei ihrem freund
findet auch schwierig wenn große
prominente frauen in ihr euch auch sagen
lieber vorsorgen als nachsorge oder
botox angebot und das dann 16 17 jährige
frauen anschauen und sagen oh ja ich
glaube ich muss zum arzt rennen und
vorsorgen das finde ich halt also ich
finde darauf geht nicht geben eine
verantwortung die die tragen müssen die
haben halt eine sehr junge zielgruppe
teilweise
guckt mich nicht so an
jobs oder
weil du lernst noch retten jetzt alle
argumente gehört hast was dann zu sagen
du hast ja klar es ist ja auch sehr
leidenschaft ja dass das dass das geht
mir auch in gewisser weise sehe ich dass
ein aber alles in allem also das 1 1
petri lombardi heute dann wird groß
drauf gewesen heute sagt ja alles dann
sitzt da und sagt eigentlich ich bin
völlig fertig ihr wisst gar nicht wie
schlecht es mir geht aber als wollte ich
erst noch 100000 kinder pietro lombardi
werden sie sagen dann heute euro da bin
ich aber froh dass ich nicht gewonnen es
ist es ist absurd es ich weiß gar nichts
anderes als das als dass ich sage ich
begreife es nicht und ich meine guck mal
werden heute diese influenza also diese
diese amanda gramm und eine tolle frau
die ich als als dichterin wahrgenommen
habe anderes als frau jelinek oder anna
seghers oder wen auch immer aber nun
höre ich dass das ein prada model ist
und dass genau das im wesentlichen die
kunst heute ist gleichzeitig
intellektuelle schriftstellerin und
prada model zu sein das war die die bei
der bei der
beiden inthronisationsball ehrlich
gesagt ziemlich groß was sie da
geleistet hat und ich glaube wir müssen
jetzt hier einfach mal gewinnt discovery
klaus findet katja metz und kursen tolle
vorbilder wir anderen sind da etwas
anderer meinung ist aber wenn du ein
solches ich sage sie sind vorbilder und
die einen sind toll und die anderen sind
nicht toll und lasst doch ihre follower
entscheiden wie sie sie finden und nicht
uns das ist dann lass doch deine kinder
entscheiden ob sie auf die herdplatte
greifen oder mit es geht ja auch im
verantwortungsbewusst
[Musik]